stress relief
stress
can we leave my mask on that's not what
i want to take off
[Music]
last week had a very steamy
scene which i was not expecting what was
the reaction that you received from the
fan base of the show
oh my gosh it's been exploding and also
just my like personal texts have been
exploding
everyone's like why didn't you tell us
about that scene
it's crazy i was very excited too
and when we read it at the table read
everyone freaked out as well and we were
like oh my gosh i hope this stays in i
hope this stays on
and it did i don't know where this is
going to go
is this going to be just a friends with
benefits
situation are they going to get back
together
i don't think that schmidt should get
back together with nico
i know a lot of people want it but know
your worth and you were not treated
properly oh my gosh i love this i feel
like i'm like
in a therapy pep talk i agree with you i
mean there's
so much controversy around this
relationship so much debate
of should they be together should they
not my opinion is
they've both sort of said where they're
at and unless they're both willing to
grow together there's certainly going to
be
some conflict there was another moment
that gooped and
gagged everyone which was the return of
patrick dempsey
how hard of a secret was it to keep that
and how great has it been to have an og
back on set
it wasn't a hard secret because i didn't
know at all
i was shocked just like everybody else
so i found out
while i was watching just like all of
you guys i was shook
ellen said that this could be the
final season of grey's anatomy which
like sent everyone into a tizzy do you
foresee this being the final season of
grey's anatomy or are you ready to
continue these stories and keep telling
them
if i had any say we would be doing a few
more seasons i'm
i feel like handwriting a bunch of
letters petitioning abc to just keep
going so
we'll see maybe i should just give them
to ellen i don't know being on
such a massive show and having that
queer representation
on screen is so important for so many
people
what kind of weight does it carry for
you to be that person
oh it's massive it's massive but i also
knew
on a wider level how much it was going
to mean to so many people who could
finally see themselves
represented in a way that maybe felt a
little bit more authentic to
them and after i came out and after levi
came out that's when i really started
seeing just how many people this
affected
i met someone and he's hot
and he's confident and he likes me
and i'm gay i to this day i still get
hundreds of messages
in my in my uh you know instagram or
twitter
every day every morning when i wake up
from queer people
around the world queer youth around the
world talking about how
they feel witnessed by this storyline
and it's um it's incredible well i'm
happy for you schmidt
thank you yeah i think it's beautiful
after all it's life forth not to share
it with somebody right i know you're
friends with
nina west from rupaul's drag race i
thought
i would love to see you as a guest judge
on rupaul's drag race
oh is that something you would do
anything i would give anything to be a
guest judgment report i just rewatched
the entire
uh show during the quarantine you know
because we have time and i'm
i'm upset i'm obsessed i would be there
tomorrow
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos